Have you got a minute?
Do you wish you had a really eye-catching way of introducing your products or services...
...or perhaps just want to explain something differently?
Are you and your customers tired of the same old same old pages and pages of text...
...on your website or in your presentations?
Wouldn't it be refreshing to use something like this,...
...which not only puts your point across, but is entertaining too?
Suddenly, through the use of our hand-drawn cartoons,...
...it becomes crystal clear what you're on about.
And most importantly, if it's on YouTube or on your website,...
...people will want to pass the link onto others.
Think viral marketing opportunities:...
...fame, chat shows, world domination.
If you want to know more about this great communication method,...
...please visit our website.
Ta-da!